Noi abbiamo due case in Sicilia
all'interno dello stesso giardino. Io
dormo in una, Giammarco dorme nell'altra,
insieme a un sacco di altri fratelli e
cugini. Indovinate dove dorme Guglielmo?
Nella casa dove non succede niente. Esatto
Cos'è successo? Il panico. Ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata di Vita
Buttata, il tema della puntata di oggi è
"Esperienze paranormali"
Per un tema così importante ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios de casa mia
una persona che possiamo definire un
professionista, una persona che ha un
rapporto con lo spiritismo, l'esoterismo,
l'astrologia veramente veramente forte
il problema è che questa persona non era
disponibile, quindi ho preso il primo che
ho incontrato per strada e ho buttato
all'interno di questo tema mio cugino
Gianmarco. Salve a tutti. Allora. Tu lo sai
che un sacco di persone ti volevano
all'interno degli studios.
Mi chiedo perché? Anch'io ma non ho
trovato una risposta. E mi chiedo il
perché tu mi abbia invitato nell'unica
puntata dove ci si c**a addosso?! Perché in
realtà Giammi le persone non lo sanno
ma noi veniamo da una famiglia molto
molto molto particolare. Eh vero. Lui è uno dei
portatori di uno dei grandi segreti
della mia famiglia, cioè una roba che ha
coinvolto la maggior parte dei miei
parenti, non me, perché io non c'ero. Sai di
cosa sto parlando? Certo certo! Come dimenticare quei
giorni nefasti. Senza contare che Gianmarco è
l'addetto di Vita Buttata. Voi non lo
sapete ma la selezione che viene fatta
forse l'ho già detto in passato, dei primi
commenti, cioè
i primi, tanti...un bel po'...grazie che arrivano, la fa lui, in
modo da riuscire a prendere proprio
quelli più giusti che poi riesco a
sentire insieme all'ospite in maniera
assolutamente spontanea per la prima
volta. Poi vabbè vengono ancora
selezionati ed è la prima volta che
tu non hai ascoltato i commenti. Hai paura?
Sono stranito, sono stranito. Spero che la troupe che hai ingaggiato sia
all'altezza? Si, I tuo fratelli. Sarò molto obiettivo e severo anche
nell'analizzarli  eh. Anche io, sisi perché è tanto facile dire...è un argomento delicato questo. Bravissimo
Allora io sono molto scettico.
Eh io il contrario invece. Perfetto!
Ho le mie credenze, non ci scherzo sopra
anche quando la realtà è troppo
paranormale, che non ha senso. Non so che cos'hai appena paradetto. Io manco ci scherzo però, stacco
Siamo pronti? Via. Una sera eravamo piccoli e avevamo una di queste prime macchine fotografiche
digitali no? Allora scegliamo di farci
una foto, ovviamente la sera, quindi col flash
Dietro di noi c'era una sedia di quelle bianche
di plastica, quelle classiche diciamo
Scattiamo questa foto, tutti a vedere
come è venuta e vediamo che in questa
sedia c'era una sagoma di una persona
seduta, ma era perfetta c'era proprio una
persona. Allora tutti ci giriamo di
scatto a guardare questa sedia, che si era
praticamente girata e poi non mi ricordo
chi, forse mia sorella
presa dal panico cancellò la foto, spegne la macchina fotografica, poi siamo rimasti
tutti in silenzio traumatizzati da
questa roba. Non l'abbiamo mai più scordato
Non me la scorderò nemmeno io quasta roba. Madonna
ragazzi. Se dovesse capitarmi morirei su colpo
sul colpo, non riuscirei nemmeno a premere
"cancella foto". Cancellerei me
dal pianeta. Mazza che freddezza sta ragazza
mi sa che staremo molto in ascolto noi in questa
puntata. Si infatti mi sto inibendo.
Ciao Gu, io da piccola vivevo in una casa in
montagna di quelle vecchissime no? Quando
non c'era nessuno si tornava o si trovava
sportelli aperti oppure insomma si sentiva
rumore o robe del genere. Durante la notte
dalla soffitta si sente piangere tipo
cicciobello, quelle bambole insomma non mi ricordo
che bambola era. Sicché la mattina il babbo
va su in soffitta per togliergli le
batterie, torna tutto bianchissimo perché
in realtà non aveva le batterie. Il male
qua sai dov'è seconde me? In chi progetta
questi giocattoli che piangono
Cioè ma che cos'è? Sì. Ma perché devi fare un bambino che piange? Ma non lo puoi fare che ride?
No aspetta. Casa vecchia dei nostri zii a Piramide. Si. C'era una casa
un po' molesta. C'è stato una sera il
pianoforte che ha iniziato a suonare
La pianolina. Tin tin tin tin. Così eh. Ecco perché se ne sono andati. Sono scappati. Che poi quando sei
piccolo i grandi te la raccontano tipo "No
allora ti spiego, delle onde
elettromagnetiche hanno fatto suonare il
pianoforte, stai tranquillo. Dov'è il
pianoforte adesso? Bruciato! Volevo raccontare una cosa che mi è capitata quand'ero bambina. La notte mi
sono svegliata e in lacrime. Quando mi
sono svegliata ho sentito dei rumori
ho pensato che mia madre sentendo col
suo orecchio radar me piangere si fosse
alzata per venire a consolarmi, quindi
mi sono alzata dal letto e ne sono
andata diciamo incontro. La mia camera è
alla fine di un corridoio e vedevo
nella penombra del corridoio una
sagoma bianca che poteva somigliare
molto a quella di mia madre, perché lei metteva
queste camicie da notte chiare. Allora
io la chiamo, le vado incontro, "mamma mamma" però arrivo alla fine del corridoio  ma non c'è
niente, assolutamente niente, mia mamma
che russa nella sua camera e io paralizzata
in mezzo al corridoio che comincio a tremare e a un certo punto sento sulla mia mano una specie di
carezza. No! C'è quella notte ho bagnato il letto. Cioè non lo so. Complimenti che l'ha solo
bagnarlo, io ci cagavo dentro. Ma che è la carezza, ma che siamo matti ragazzi?
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, io prima di andare alle superiori ogni mattina mentre chiudevo la porta di casa sentivo
dei bambini che mi salutavano. Ho chiesto a mia
madre che cosa sarebbe potuto essere e
lei mi ha detto che lei sentiva i piedini di questi bambini e quindi un giorno lei
mi disse "Guarda prova, prova a salutarli". Un
giorno li ho salutati anche io mentre uscivo
di casa e da quel giorno non li ho più sentiti.
Mazza oh, consiglio materno
Ma la madre...ma sua madre che è Magamagò? Cioè io se mio figlio
venisse da me a dire "Papà guarda sento i
bambini che... ti prego! Vai
Vattene andiamocene via". E' arrivata mia cugina, e quindi niente abbiamo un'altra persona che viene
a farci sostegno. Volevo raccontare di
quella volta in cui ero in Polonia a
casa di mia nonna,
ad un certo punto, era tutto spento,  io ero in
camera con la porta aperta, mia nonna era al
piano di sotto io al piano di sopra
Inizio a sentire dei passi forti sulle scale,
controllo chi c è sulle scale, se sta a salì
mia donna no? Non c'era nessuno era tutto
buio. Risento questi passi e mia nonna
da giù di sotto urla "Ma che stai facendo
su di sopra?"
Abbiamo controllato tutta la casa per
vedere se ci fossero ladri o che, guardiamo
se ci fossero ladri, se era entrato
qualcuno in casa non si sapeva e la casa era
totalmente chiusa, quindi insomma non
poteva essere entrato nessuno
Enrico. Che è successo? Enrico, cos'è che faceva ridere? Era due ore che Giulia mi fa "Era il vicino"
Noi abbiamo due case in Sicilia
all'interno dello stesso giardino, io
dormo in una, Gianmarco dorme nell'altra
insieme a un sacco di altri fratelli e
cugini. Indovinate dove dorme Guglielmo?
Nella casa dove non succede niente. Esatto
Cosa è successo? Il panico.
Fondamentalmente questa casa è a due piani
e le scale quando tu sali scricchiolano,
per cui tu senti chiaramente quando stai
al secondo piano, all'interno di una delle stanze
quando sta salendo qualcuno e poi
diciamo che nel disimpegno alla fine delle
scale dovresti vedere comparire la
persona quando fa proprio l'ultimo,
l'ultimo scalino. Esatto. Ma loro non la
vedevano mai. Eravamo molto pochi, c'eravamo io
e gli altri tuoi fratelli. C'era un
periodo che non so per quale motivo io
leggevo Harry Potter ad alta voce no?
Ah si. Come ninna nanna per i tuoi fratelli.
Ero il più erudito in quella stanza quindi
pensa un po' a che livello siamo no? Eri l'unico capace di
leggere diciamo in quella stanza, quindi
leggevi...leggevo, già c'erano stati dei
campanelli di allarme, tipo "ragazzi ma
per caso ogni tanto sentite dei rumori
sulle scale, percepite qualche strano
rumore, qualcosa del genere?
Sì, cioè di base è stato un sì unanime
però l'esperienza che vi racconterò è
una testimonianza di tutti noi
contemporaneamente.
Chiaramente voi sentite i passi sulle
scale? Tutti. Io stavo leggendo, tu immaginati
come se senti qualcuno che sale le scale
Ci alziamo, andiamo a vedere, Gabriele
aveva un mitra AK 47. Ma di quelli
finti con i pallini vero? Sisi certo.
Siamo arrivati a un punto che Gabriele
ogni volta che sentiamo i rumori
usciva col mitra e cominciava a sparare
sotto alle scale. Ghostbusters. E la fase
successiva era impasticcarsi di
valeriana per andare a dormire. Ma ce ne
stanno eh, facciamo notte se le raccontiamo tutte
Si noi ne abbiamo veramente ragazzi,
noi abbiamo storie di spiritismo perché
in sicilia in quel periodo evidentemente,
andava di moda fare le sedute spiritiche
cioè noi se famo una stories su Instagram, loro evocavano un morto. Colpi di tosse...le nostre madri
sono testimoni di sedute spiritiche.
Diciamo siamo una famiglia un po'
particolare per chi non l'avesse capito eh.
Si per un periodo eravamo gli Addams
la versione sicula "We Mottisia"
Ero a letto stavo dormendo da un po' di ore, era notte inoltrata, e improvvisamente il letto ha iniziato
a muoversi, come se fosse strattonato continuamente da qualcosa. Ho pensato ci fosse un terremoto
ma nessuno della mia famiglia si era svegliato. Alché mi sono girata dall'altro lato verso il muro
e il letto ha ripreso a muoversi velocissimo, fortissimo come se
qualcuno lo stesse strattonando. Il giorno dopo chiesi alla mia famiglia se c'era stato un terremoto
se avessero sentito qualcosa e nessuno aveva sentito niente
Lei poi si è riaddormentata. Si in effetti. Io avrei preso una sega elettrica, se non l'avessi avuta la sega elettrica
sarei uscita, me la sarei procurata o avrei preso anche solamente un coltellino e avrei
demolito il letto, sventrato il materasso
e dormito sulla nuda pietra. Gabriele col
ventilatore? Sempre nella... sempre in
quella camera dove stavamo tutti noi
Mamma mia io c'ho visto lungo. Si è alzato
nella notte e il ventilatore era acceso
Vai raccontala te che non me la ricordo bene
Ha preso, ha preso le coperte...si è coperto completamente ed è tornato a dormire
Cioè non l'ha spento di nuovo? Ma vacce dal ventilatore che si è appena acceso. Ritornaci
Io proverei di nuovo a spegnerlo e direi "Vai",
se risuccede una seconda volta allora c'è
qualcosa che non torna. Bravo. Cioè capito? Io
voglio vedere se funziona. Mi c**o sotto ma mi
sale pure la cosa tipo "Dai non è
possibile che ora c'è lo spirito che..."
Ma che spirito è? Il gioco del
ventilatore con lo spirito. Cioè vieni
dall'aldilà, ma vieni a giocà col
ventilatore? Perdonami mi i*****o si con lo spirito
Riesce a superare i piani per accendermi
il ventilatore? Eh ma hai visto, l'hai visto Ghost?
Che esercizio devono fare i fantasmi per...
Si e l'hai visto Harry Potter che esercizio
devono fare per lanciare Avada Kedavra?
Stasera succederà qualcosa, sono troppo
sprezzante nei confronti dell'Oltretomba. Io mi devo prendere una pausa, facciamo così
Questo video sta diventando
veramente come, come la cassetta di The
Ring, secondo me le persone lo guardano e
a un certo punto ricevono una chiamata
Lo posteremo non lo so tra...come? Sette
giorni. La seconda parte del video la
mettiamo giovedì prossimo sempre alle 14.
Ora io mi faccio tre ore di Ave Maria, atto di
dolore e riprendiamo ad ascoltarli,
perché sennò non arriviamo a domani
Io mi faccio di qualche droga pesante. Grazie per essere
rimasti qui, per il momento rimaniamo
così sospesi, nel frattempo iscrivetevi e
attivate la notifica per non perdere il
video della prossima settimana.
Ciao ci vediamo fra sette giorni